[Música]
y continuamos con nuestra Crónica de
economía de la mano de Juan Pablo lucumí
Juan Pablo bienvenido otra vez acá
estamos otra vez con información de
último minuto y la información de último
minuto ya usted la ha anunciaba Y es que
Estados Unidos reveló el informe sobre
cómo está el empleo en ese país Cómo
está Pues María Clara hubo sorpresas y
los datos superaron todos los
pronósticos el crecimiento de empleo fue
mejor de lo esperado en abril a pesar de
la agitación bancaria y una economía en
desaceleración Wall Street y economistas
encuestados por routers habían estimado
un crecimiento de 180.000 empleos en
abril pero el dato fue mucho mayor y ya
lo veremos la tasa de desempleo fue el
3,4% frente a una estimación del 3,6%
también que se consagró como Pues el mes
de abril como el nivel más bajo desde
1969 vamos a mirar Entonces los números
las nóminas entonces aumentaron en 253
mil empleos en abril desde el pronóstico
Perdón desde marzo que estaba en 165.000
podemos un incremento significativo aquí
el desempleo entonces cayó 3,4% se ubicó
en abril desde el 3,5 de marzo y el
promedio de ganancias por hora de manera
intermensual es decir Comparado mes a
mes fue el 0,5% frente al 0,3 de marzo
para el promedio salarial que este tema
ya es interanual Comparado pues
anualizado es del 4,4% en abril desde el
4,3 en todos los datos hubo Pues de
manera sorpresiva Para abril ahora
veamos cómo ha sido el panorama de
crecimiento de empleo en Estados Unidos
desde el año pasado y como puede ver
aunque un incremento en este mes de
abril todavía pues no llega a los picos
del año pasado esto para los meses de
octubre de noviembre pero si supera el
mes inmediatamente anterior como usted
puede ver ahí en la barra de crecimiento
y aún así es un aumento bastante notable
que son casi 100.000 empleos adicionales
en un solo mes Así es es bastante y pues
Eso lo veremos como afectó a los
mercados bueno sigamos en Estados Unidos
pero con otra noticia porque la Casa
Blanca ya le está dando la advertencia a
las grandes tecnológicas que están
dedicadas a desarrollar la Inteligencia
artificial qué están diciendo pues los
directivos ejecutivos de Google
Microsoft opening y antrópicas
asistieron a la reunión de dos horas
sobre el desarrollo y La regulación de
la Inteligencia artificial el jueves por
invitación de la vicepresidenta de
Estados Unidos kamala Harris entre otras
cosas que sucedieron en la reunión vamos
a destacar algunos de los mensajes en
ese momento pues el primer mensaje es
que los directivos de esas empresas
deben tener una moral o debe o un deber
moral para garantizar que la
Inteligencia artificial no dañe a la
sociedad la vicepresidenta por ejemplo
dijo abro comillas las compañías deben
cumplir con las leyes existentes para
proteger al pueblo estadounidense y el
presidente Joe biden dijo abro comillas
Espero que puedan educar sobre lo creen
que es más necesario para proteger a la
sociedad así como para el avance y
también dijo que pues esto es un enorme
potencial y un enorme peligro también
para la sociedad esta reunión se produjo
en el marco de una inversión de 140
millones de dólares que la
administración de biden hizo para siete
nuevos institutos de investigación de
Inteligencia artificial la creación de
un comité independiente para la
evaluación y todo un panorama también de
regulación de diferentes medidas esto
Dijo la vicepresidenta en sus redes
sociales los avances en tecnología
siempre presentan nuevas oportunidades y
desafíos la Inteligencia artificial
generativa no es diferente hoy me reuní
con los directores ejecutivos de las
empresas a la vanguardia de estos
avances para discutir la responsabilidad
que tienen los gobiernos y las empresas
de mitigar los riesgos para proteger al
público el mes pasado el director
ejecutivo de tesla elon musk y el
cofundador de Apple Steve snack hacían
parte de los 1.300 firmantes de una
carta abierta que pedía Una pausa de 6
meses en el entrenamiento de sistemas de
Inteligencia artificial
argumentado entre otras cosas que hasta
que no se esté seguro de esto pues no se
debería avanzar
potencial es la gran pregunta
artificial lo decía la ética es el
factor que va a resolver todo esto
Cuáles son los indicadores Empezando por
Estados Unidos empecemos Entonces por
Wall Street porque en Estados Unidos
abrió en positivo como resultado de los
buenos datos de empleabilidad que
sorprendieron a todo el mundo hasta los
inversores de Wall Street y ya vimos los
números las bolsas europeas siguen
operando en terreno positivo también
movidas por la senda alcista de Wall
Street América Latina cerró ayer
indecisa el indicador y Bob es para de
Brasil fue el índice que lideró las
alzas entre sus pares de la región
Mientras que el merval de Argentina fue
el que más desplomó al cierre y otra de
las noticias en América Latina Juan
Pablo aparte de los indicadores es lo
que está ocurriendo en Venezuela con la
gasolina cuéntenos más y es
específicamente en Maracaibo Venezuela
porque desde esta semana se viralizaron
vídeos de carros que se incendiaban de
forma espontánea es decir sin ninguna
razón aparente o una falla técnica
algunos expertos consultados por la
agencia de noticias afp señalan que todo
podría ser por la mala calidad de la
gasolina distribuida en Maracaibo pero a
la compañía de petróleos de Venezuela
niega esta versión escuchemos lo que
denuncian los venezolanos el que salió
mal la pila ya yo trabajo ya Como hace
10 marcas y todo hace lo mismo o sea el
problema no la pila el problema es 100%
de la gasolina no esto es nuevo para
nosotros esto ahorita es nuevo porque
viene pasando Desde que
hubieron estos problemas
esperemos que resuelvan lo más pronto
posible porque ya uno Tienes miedo de
salir a la calle con un vehículo de
forma técnica los expertos han dicho que
debido a la falta de disolventes la
gasolina distribuida es muy corrosiva y
tiene altas concentraciones de azufre lo
que Por ende daña las bombas de
combustible de los coches y aumenta el
riesgo de incendio Maracaibo a pesar de
ser la antigua capital petrolera del
país ha sufrido una escasez recurrente
de combustible durante más de una década
agravada por el contrabando y cuál es la
cifra de este viernes bueno son los 400
millones de euros en ventas perdidas que
le costó Adidas luego de la ruptura
entre la compañía alemana y El rapero
estadounidense kanye West hizo popular
marca de los GPS pese a esto este
viernes reportó unas ganancias
operativas trimestrales de 60 millones
de euros superando las expectativas de
los 15 millones de euros la superó con
creces Gracias Juan Pablo por todas las
noticias económicas aquí en directo y el
lunes con mucho más de economía